What is surprising about the United States of America is that he is actually a United Nations of a bunch of countries.
At the beginning, there were only 13 countries.
But as time progressed, the map gradually went west
To the 48 countries we joined together today, plus Alaska and Hawaii
Hawaii and Alaska are not like other countries that are grouped together because
It is located in the middle of the entire great waterway, while Alaska is only mad.
Unlike other federal countries, you can say that you want to break up and break up.
And can also permanently retain the national status of the country喔
Just telling you! Texas!
And the way the federal government works is another story.
But now, all you need to know is that the national law is
A congress formed by representatives of small countries.
Going back to the map, there are still some non-state borders that are inconspicuous on the map.
The first to bear the brunt is Washington, DC, the capital of the first good
And he was forgotten between Maryland and Virginia.
The SAR is a non-state city controlled by Congress.
That is to say, all states have to look at the face of Washington, DC.
And it has no voting rights itself.
Even in the SAR, there is actually no one living in it.
But when more and more people live in the SAR than in other states,
The situation may not be very good.
There are other American Indian reservations on the map.
In fact, quite a lot
The heads of the states regard them as foreign territories to some extent.
In other words, they will look like this.
After all, the reserved area is separated from other states.
The American Indian Reservation is a variety of markers.
awkward...
It’s another story here.
Let’s not talk about the border topic. These squares are just the best.
But the United States is actually not only these
Saying that after the land was divided
I learned how to be a big island owner from my mom.
First debut: Puerto Rico - concept of top floor stamping (US non-established territories)
In the name of the state, it is actually doing it on its own (to some extent)
And the US Constitution is not completely covered.
Looking at the island, there are 3.7 million people living in Puerto Rico today.
That is to say, 91% of people live on the islands of the United States.
Others live in the territory of the other 21 states.
And Puerto Rico is considered a country by the United States, in addition to its name.
It should be almost in the near future.
Bring maybe the 51st star to the United States?
But Puerto Rico is not the only top-floor capped territory (a non-established territories in the United States).
This is Guam, earned after winning the West-American War.
In addition to Puerto Rico, Northern Mariana Islands
Earned from the Japanese during the Second World War
Then the Virginia Islands were sold from the Danish mom.
People living in these places are considered US citizens.
For the most part, these territories are like Washington, DC.
Congress can overthrow these local governments and they don’t
The reason for the representation is because they are not a "true. country"
Otherwise, American
In fact, these territories, like Washington, DC, are all elected to Congress.
Go to all meetings
But that is, I can’t be one of them.
It can be said that the most embarrassing work is also the coolest.
It’s just what kind of people are going to interpret it.
In addition, since the election of the president is based on the state population
Citizens in these territories are unable to vote
Leading to a strange situation in the previous film
Americans living in foreign countries can follow their previous
The state in which the state resides has the power to elect the president
The Americans living in the United States are only living on the top floor and stamped (the US non-established territories).
Can't vote
Except for non-consolidated territories
There are also so-called: non-consolidated non-formed territories
Honestly, there is not much
Like Howland Island, Nafsha Island
Wake Island, Jarvis Island
Johnston Atoll, Kingman Reef, Midway Reef
Serra Nile shoal, Bajo Nuevo shoal
Most of these islands are obtained through the "Bird Island Bill"
When the United States wants a pile of small islands filled with guanines
Truly do not lie, the United States is directly written, the law of the plaintiff declares
All hers (my, I said)
There is no establishment on this system, which means there is no local government on these islands.
Because no one lives in these bird places.
Some places are even just above the Haiping line.
Again, there is another kind of strange (United States non-merged territory)
One of them: Pamela Atoll
After the United States and the crabs swallowed Hawaii
And they have recently been used as natural reserves.
However, non-merger means that the US Constitution applies to this.
Who is it for? The problem with the Pamela Atoll is like if a tree falls in the forest.
If there is no person in the constitution that can make the constitution applicable
So is the constitution still applicable?
Yes
This means that if there is a foreigner born in a place where the bird does not lay eggs
And not dying from the ruthless nature
Their children can become American citizens
Currently, this category has not been established yet.
And this will be a classification before becoming a state.
When the constitution is fully applicable
And finally occupied by Hawaii
After we circled a large circle, we also missed a piece of land.
American Samoa: 55,000 people
Uniquely, American Samoans are not citizens
Instead, become a national of the United States
They can live in the state but can't participate in the presidential election
Unless they are like any foreigner through immigration procedures
Even through any channel, they are different from citizens.
What is more amazing about American Samoans is that there seems to be nothing more than Congress.
More dragging reasons to update the law
American Samoa belongs to the category of anarchy, just like the case of the king of flies
But it’s obviously not the same thing.
So American Samoa with a formed government should move here.
Then Puerto Rico, basically a state, needs to be here.
Then the empty Pamela Atoll needs to be moved here.
But don’t do these things for Congress.
Have too much expectation
Ok, just all of it is the territory of the United States. There is still the last here.
One thing to come up with to talk about: Three small countries -- oh, Marshall Islands and
Federated States of Micronesia
The Federated States of Micronesia has a convenient domain name: .fm -- the first choice for podcasters everywhere
Here, here: Click 喔
These small countries with United Nations seats
They also have a relationship with the United States.
Free contact contract
This agreement is provided by the United States for financial assistance and military defense.
To the agreement country, exchange the right to build a military base in the country
In addition, citizens of the country of agreement can also live and work in the United States, and vice versa.
Americans want to live abroad: you have three simple options.
So, the above is the United States: 50 states, many reserved areas, a special zone,
a large number of island territories, and three related small countries